hi steve kaufman here
and today i want to talk about a subject
that often comes up what is the easiest
language to learn
okay
before i get into that if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe click on
the bell for notifications if you follow
me on a podcast
uh please leave a review
so
is there an easier language
i think here
there are both um subjective factors and
objective factors which you have to
consider
all right so i think the most important
consideration is how motivated are you
to learn the language
uh because if you are very motivated the
the difficulties the objective
difficulties which i'll get into
will kind of disappear so when it comes
to which language is easiest you have to
begin by saying which language am i most
motivated to learn all right
a second consideration is
to what extent is it easy to find
interesting material compelling input in
that language
i have to confess that i have had
difficulty with some languages where it
has been difficult to find compelling
input korean czech in some ways
whereas other languages
where there's lots of content available
on the internet especially today
like russian like spanish like english
it's a lot easier
i'm struggling a bit now with arabic and
persian
i have recently found some really good
stuff in arabic and once i get a hold of
some compelling content it spurs me on
it influences my
my confidence my enthusiasm
so um
obviously a subjective factor then is
how interested are you in the language
uh can you find compelling input
in that language another thing is uh
confident levels confidence level if you
sort of think you can't or whatever if
you're so you're not interested or you
can't find interesting content and you
think you can't learn it it's going to
be very difficult for you whereas if you
are convinced that you can do it this is
another subjective consideration that i
think is very important
and uh
as in any language learning situation
you have to take the initiative you have
to take the initiative to go out there
and find content of interest and pursue
things that are of interest to you so
those are some of the subjective
considerations but
there is one factor that's kind of a
combination of subjective and
and objective so
rather than saying language x is
the most difficult or the easiest to a
large extent it depends on the languages
you already know
so because to me vocabulary is the
biggest issue language learning is about
learning words so if you speak a
language say you speak spanish and you
want to learn italian obviously 85 of
the words in italian are identifiable as
being similar to spanish even allowing
for the odd false friend which really
doesn't matter there aren't so many of
them the fact that the vocabulary is
similar is going to help you
similarly for an english speaker
spanish french all of the latin based
languages have a lot of vocabulary in
common with english so i think the
vocabulary is the biggest issue it's a
bigger issue i think than grammar
because we can get used to the grammar
in time we'll get used to the grammar
but if we have
to learn and relearn and forget and
relearn and there's so many words to
learn
that makes the language more difficult
for example
romanian has a grammatical structure
that's
quite unique they have a number of
unique features however 70 percent of
their vocabulary is very similar to
other romance languages and so with that
romanian becomes quite easy to learn
despite its different
grammatical structure so is the
vocabulary in the language you want to
learn similar to a language you already
know so that means that for example for
a person who
say a japanese speaker they've got the
characters in japanese and they've got a
lot of the vocabulary even
koreans who don't use chinese characters
a lot of their vocabulary 50 just as the
case with the japanese
is of chinese origin so they have an
easier time whereas say europeans or
people from north america or from the
middle east or from somewhere else where
they don't have this vocabulary it's
going to be more difficult for them
now another
objective consideration is things like
the writing system obviously if it's
it's much easier to learn a language
that's written in your own writing
system because since you were a child
you've been reading in that writing
system so to get the brain even if you
understand how chinese characters work
or arabic writing
it's going to be difficult to get used
to reading it comfortably quickly so
that and since reading is such a big
part of language learning
if you can't read comfortably it's going
to slow you down
so that's an objective consideration
now of the different writing systems
some of them are very much parallel to
the latin alphabet and that's the case
with cyrillic or with greek others are
true alphabets like the hangul but very
different
and then you have syllabaries like
japanese hiragana katakana and then you
have
i should point out by the way the arabic
script is also an alphabet but it's for
me difficult to get used to
um and then you have chinese characters
which are even more difficult so writing
system is a big consideration another
objective consideration is grammar i
find that of the languages that i have
learned
the slavic languages have the most
complicated grammar more
case endings to try to remember while
you're speaking
certain concepts like
aspects of verbs verbs of motion that i
found difficult but i have never had to
struggle with
issues in english like articles so maybe
for speakers of those other languages
the articles in english
and maybe some other things make english
difficult so it it again gets back to
this idea that certain languages are
subjectively
easier or difficult
i know that the foreign service
institute in the united states has put
out you know their evaluation of how
many instructional hours are required
for different languages and on that
basis they
rate them by level of difficulty but
that's typically based on
an english speaker in a classroom
so
how relevant that is to
anybody out there who doesn't happen to
be an english speaker studying in a
classroom i don't know but it's also a
bit of an indicator of the level of
difficulty of different languages so
easiest to learn i would say for an
english speaker is spanish
german is somewhat more complicated in
his grammar and i haven't done a study
but i have the feeling that the
vocabulary between english and spanish
is more similar than english and german
although there's a lot of vocabulary in
german that helps us i don't think
either of those languages is nearly as
difficult as languages where we have no
common vocabulary arabic or persian or
obviously chinese so i hope that's
helpful a little bit of a discussion on
the difficulty of different languages
and i'll leave you with a couple of
videos i've done on the same subject